[Music]
in fast food fight news oh this is the
one I saw this one yeah
submitted by waffle fries they're so
[ __ ] good
chick-fil-a waffle fries oh my god
seasoned waffle fries
jack-in-the-box walk with Bryson any
waffle fries something but the damn cut
I know what you mean I know what you
mean why does it make it taste different
when it's the same thing as waffle fries
why does the shady buddy make it
different it's the ratio now I think cuz
you're getting more crispy ratio did you
know the Browning while cooking food is
actually a flavor agent yeah browning
yeah Browning is like so so I would
assume that since you have more surface
area to fry that maybe the Browning
sizes so you bite into something that is
flat and there's more crunch there's
more of that instead of one long stick
of crunch yeah I never had you still
like soggy you awful fries - well to me
waffle fries aren't super crispy like
they're more mushy this is you I had a
good one that's why or to you that's a
good one anyways I like them there's
only one thing I hate about you and
that's it alone I could never have
waffle fries without ranch
I need ranch with my waffle fries I need
ranch and ketchup I mixed sometimes
mustard too huh and mustard yeah depends
on what the fry is know if I bring in
the mustard it's just ketchup and muscle
your fries are what ethics what's going
on right now I just put black pepper
inside there's a chick-fil-a next to my
house did it open yeah and the first
down everyone know where you live
there's like oh I know I'm helping more
and say that really I live on 679 why
did you tell them I know Oh everybody's
gonna go to holy boy Street now are you
going to chick-fil-a on hooli bully
street no don't tell everybody he's also
a whack-a-mole lane so oh come on really
eutteum the cross had to do it
whack-a-mole Lane seven nine three six
their kids name is Keita
all right McDuck's employee was punched
and choked by a woman upset over ketchup
haggis this one we're talking about
people
bad day you know what though they do
piss me off because they don't give you
any ketchup you have to ask for it oh
it's a piss you off then give me a hand
okay do you eat it there do you eat that
that's like this that's like this hey
what if I gave you a drink with the cap
on and no [ __ ] straw and you're like
what the [ __ ] man where's the strife
well I'll put it to you like this though
we have a [ __ ] ton of ketchup packets
here for no [ __ ] reason yes this guy
right here he goes I need a [ __ ] ton of
ketchup like a lot so he gets to like
handfuls of it and he only uses like
four who I use a lot of ketchup you know
I use a kitchen and we have a whole
ketchup on I use a lot of it but then he
just doesn't like the temperature
temperature change which I feel you want
I give a specific number out because I
know what is it I'll be like give me six
that's a good number I feel like that
don't get you through a large yeah
that's a good number actually and then
you'll have the security of the extra
packet cuz it's nerve-racking when
you're down to the last nugget the last
frying they do this at like any like
other fast-food place like Taco Bell
talk or whatever when I got to calculate
the sauce love you like give me 2 per
taco and then I got to calculate that I
like ketchup so much I could get like
three ketchup I could take the packet I
could suck the whole ketchup packet eat
three fries well I used to eat ketchup
Wow when I was hungry
yeah ketchup the [ __ ] dude Oh Danny
sweet vinegar and how much food my
little salty just ketchup yes a bunch of
sugar that's why it's so [ __ ] good
I've been that sly it said I like salt
and pepper better yeah I'm the salt and
pepper person so what's going on with
McDonald's kids this one she ordered her
food through the drive-through oh I know
what that's like in Santa Ana oh I know
where that's at lots of stress there
specifically within the city boundaries
she asked for ketchup but she didn't
like the amount that she received so she
went inside through an employee's and
you should have no [ __ ] you don't leave
the drive-thru they always give you like
three they're trained to give you two
and then you go yeah can I get more
please you have to ask for
- first cuz I never get ketchup yes
automatically anymore can I get some
ketchup please
it is like - it's like [ __ ] I ordered
five large fries why are you gonna give
me two pieces of ketchup [ __ ]
you guys remember bucket of fries it
came in the cup get the large cup or
extra-large Cup and they filled it up
with fries yeah it was dumb - just in
general with the ketchup packet they
haven't changed the amount size and
these packets are so [ __ ] stupid
this is just what chick-fil-a does a
good move my mind the first time I want
to chick-fil-a I'm like what this is
genius squeeze or dead chick-fil-a man
it's a good amount of ketchup you just
need like two of those and you know you
know the chick-fil-a the little thing
that they give you did you know that you
can put it on top of your [ __ ] drink
and you open it like this and then you
could dip and then the straw comes
through here you could drink it like
that no I saw that picture I saw that
and I was like is anyone going that
extra mind Wolfie I always get the
sandwich so I never get those fingers so
I might get it just to do there I'm
against chicken singers they be treating
me right I'm just saying you know
actually a few years ago this was like
15 years ago or so I went to a
chick-fil-a opening in Gloucester County
that's why I'm from Virginia
Gloucester's like low key like hella
racist if anyone knows what it is y'all
know over there in Guinea but yeah so I
went there and I was refused service
because I was in an interracial
relationship they literally just skipped
over us and they were like net like we
got to the front of the line and they
just didn't make eye contact with us
they were like next and you know what I
still love chick-fil-a cuz that [ __ ] is
so good so [ __ ] good it's so good I
remember when when the with this so I
broke out within and out they were like
in and out contributed money to a
Republican Party I was like I was
literally refused artistry black and I
still have chick-fil-a like at least
twice a month that's cuz you got morals
because it's the worker it's not the
whole entire [ __ ] company I mean also
stuff like I don't know just like I saw
that should break out in in and not like
everyone was trying to tweet like oh my
god boycott in and out and I'm like
that's not gonna happen
thank you Michael boy you're talking to
Californians like absolutely not they're
like you could get the most liberal
[ __ ] on earth and don't be like
oh no not my in and out yeah yep you
trying to tell a Californian to [ __ ]
boycott in and out as I tell you
somebody to not drink water yeah at the
CEO came out said I hate chinks I'm
still eating it I would do a whole rant
video as I'm eating the burger you know
I have to do a personal value I'll get
mad at you with the spread and putting
it all out like looking at the
chick-fil-a thing is this is patented
but let's see y'all need to get the [ __ ]
over it like about eating it - I'm just
like oh this is gonna be like a legit
food review screenshot of this woman who
went in is she posing for a [ __ ]
Instagram picture look like she about to
be somebody's ass over some ketchup yeah
the shot we're getting out of the car no
it's uh she went inside her leaving the
restaurant because some some guy that
she was with came inside the restaurant
grabbed her oh because she was attacking
the employees oh my god
but why'd you have to attack them when
there's like a dispenser you could just
dispense as much you want what you went
in the store yeah I don't know
apparently it just led to that wave
inside the store
oh yeah the pump their video do you want
to see it yeah yeah oh no this is bad oh
no okay oh she's all the way in there oh
my god oh my god those look customers
yeah I think they're still trying to
attend to the drive-thru people - you're
still doing their job that's dope
that is dope what if one of them knew
jiu-jitsu tapped her ass out she came in
quick yeah oh my god oh damn that's the
home you know you saw that she was
pulling on her hair trying to get her
off
and if she's still serving customers you
see that she open a door [ __ ] gave
her a drink you know so funny happening
she's like she's like what were your
place okay yeah yeah so those guys
running in he's like oh [ __ ] let me get
this girl Samus being in the back so the
police are also looking for the guy but
not because he's in trouble but just
because hopefully that would lead to
girl's arrest although they haven't
found her yet come on man it's not worth
day oh my god get her ass she's walking
out so calm yeah dude and I too when
she's like this
that's super just slip and just [ __ ]
calm I feel like he probably came in
there cuz he said damn this is my fault
because something happened probably says
some maybe Kim was the one that wanted
more ketchup I feel her rage Oh what if
it was like he was just saying that but
you ain't gonna do [ __ ] though and he
turned around and he was like whispers
go [ __ ] so here's the other ones that
she's got anger problems
I don't think so there's another
McDonald's one that went viral where
this employee so she was cooking and she
was eating the bacon as she was cooking
so the manna taste testing right yeah
the manager told her I stopped eating it
and then that's when the like it just
escalated to an argument the employee
like grab the bacon slap the manager Wow
the brick is like this small they got
the skinniest bacon in the world the
baking is like the size of my harmonica
right here and then like this fight
happened you can't really see much but
it's just then like pulling at each
other it's reported that the employee
hit the manager with bacon cause I would
never ever waste bacon like I [ __ ]
love bacon do ya I do
I [ __ ] love bacon oh my god it's hard
to not eat it while you're sitting there
working I worked in the kitchen for a
minute I eat everybody [ __ ] and y'all
know postmates they eatin 100% they are
mm-hmm
I would do the exact same thing some
dude was a post week's driver and he was
talking about how the order took too
long so he gets in the restaurant and
they're like sir we're so sorry it took
so long we've added in a complimentary
kid's meal for for your order and they
don't know it's post mates they're just
trying to like save face and so he gets
in the car and he's got this dilemma
he's like soda let me give me the kids
be ya know you can real meal and you
tell other people hey they only gave you
a kid's meal ready go that's even better
well can't they call the restaurant but
I mean like what
post mates involved it's like the medium
yeah most people don't want to call it
restaurant
yeah when things get late I don't blame
ya yeah yeah everybody eating your food
if you're not watching people don't take
a little snack
I get full refunds
[Music]